hello everyone and worked pretty well
all right so I'm Daniel I'm a PhD
student at Virginia Tech I'm a data
engineer at the University of Virginia
I've done some work teaching for a data
camp and the carpentry x' jared has
literally doubled my work trying to
start this conference and made me do
this talk I'm involved with the DC
meetup system here so if you guys may
have seen me around
I am also today's event photographer I
do some scuba diving stuff snowboarding
stuff and then I do some Python stuff
like Jared mentioned I talked out a
bunch of this version of this conference
at our in New York so originally in 2015
I talked about using shiny in 2016 I
talked about testing your code and then
in 2017 and talked about all the random
tools or skills you need to do data
science and then last or earlier this
year we talked about just the
infrastructure like all like are all the
various servers you need to run a data
science show so what does this all have
in common it's really how I do my work
it's what I teach my students and
usually when I go talk at meetups and it
all revolves around just how do you work
together with multiple people and then
how do you know the things that you run
are correct and so today's talk is
really about structuring your data
science project because I really just
want stuff to run our has a pretty good
ecosystem about getting that all
organized and if you really think about
it many people have the same problems
and the more and more you think about
you realize everyone just converges to
roughly the same solution and for today
it doesn't matter where you are in your
learning path hopefully you learned
something at least one thing that's
usually the goal for everything I talk
about and you know at the end of the day
I just want stuff to run at the end the
first time around right I don't want to
mess around with stuff so the data set
will be talking working with comes from
Hadley with them tidy data paper
specifically the billboard data set
and it's cool because if you go to the
repository he actually has the raw data
the raw billboard data and then the R
code itself that he used to tidy it so
we'll be working with that and so this
begins the tale of two dialects that had
that tidy data paper was originally
written before the tidy verse came
around so well we'll take the original
code and kind of translate it into
modern tasks tidy verse code so the
first thing for me if I really want it
to run Hadleys code you know you might
end up writing something like this you
know clear your environment set your
working directory and then below is the
code that Hadley had you can also see
what I have highlighted he there's a lot
of columns involved in this data set and
you know oops
Hadley actually has it all written down
and then at the end of the day down here
you know he converts everything into
ASCII text do some string replacement
rename the column so it just says wk and
then the week number reorganize and the
data frame and then some of the songs so
these are like songs in year 2000
they're just really long and we just
make them a little shorter City effect
on the screen and so you end up with the
dataset like this you can see for a
given song you have like it's ranking
billboard ranking from like week one to
week 72 I think and you can also just
take that thing I said and just condense
it and rewrite it in tidy verse world
right and like doing something like this
it really like took me an hour and a
half figuring this out and back of the
car so like it's not just because I show
it to you doesn't mean that it's really
that simple
but then the nice thing about tidy verse
is you no longer have to specify like
all of those columns right you can just
say like I want all the cons from here
to here and then it saves you a lot of
typing and then there's this like one
bit that I just like gave up trying to
figure out how to do an entire verse
world so I just just went back they
sorry
and then you end up with roughly like
the same data set right so let us do a
demo does that work all right cool the
first bit that we will do is will tidy
our data set so you can imagine you saw
that we had a different column for each
week and then so what we really want is
the data set where each row just has a
song the week number and then it's
column right we didn't want like week
one to 72 in our data set so we end up
cleaning that part up and then saving
that out what we also want to do is
normalize our data so song information
is repeated and so me as a data engineer
this all goes into a database how do we
get at this to take up less space you
know we break up our data set into two
pieces just the song information just
the rank information and then we can do
some exploratory data analysis so here
for example we can look at the average
ranking across songs and then the red
line just shows what the rank is a year
later so that kind of makes sense songs
just drop off after you go you can also
do it by month so average rank by month
so you know songs tend to just rank
higher in November but that could just
be maybe more songs or being released at
the end of the year I don't know but
that's what exploring your data is for
and then and then you can do the same
thing but what's then and then my
question was hey maybe it really matters
I like what month something starts and
then so we can draw a plot like that and
then you wonder like what is this random
little peak here and so you know that
really that peak was roughly like 27
weeks after a song was released in
December so that's what that was maybe
that has some meaning I don't know and
then at the end maybe you want to fit a
model so let's look at how does does
week just the number just the week
cannot predict like its rank and you
know you can fit the model draw out the
plot for that model and you know maybe
we don't care about the intercept
because we're not trying to interpret
the intercept so roughly you can see the
at least the point is the minute
every given week the rank is dropping by
one school one point alright so what you
can do is then you know put in all the
models for all the artists and sort it
out and just because it sumed out but
you can kind of look like Missy Elliott
down here isn't really doing too well in
the year 2000 all right so you saw you
saw what I did and you know Jenny
Brian's talked about this setting the
working directory of removing clearing
your clearing your environment and then
so what's really wrong with setting a
working directory it's really because
you're assuming a folder structure your
hard coding something in collaborators
can't collaborate computer might not
have the same structure etc etc and in
version control system don't like that
so the way you fix that make a project
you can do this in our studio it really
only adds these two files down here into
your your environment and then you know
you might say maybe it's ooh maybe our
CV projects assume everyone's using our
studio yes that's true
but if you use other things Emacs allows
you to set a working directory when you
load it up and then when you're just
running code the CD command and Linux
that's really setting your working
directory so if you could just find that
file you know where to run everything
what's wrong with the RM command well
mainly because it doesn't be patched
packages so when you run your scripts
you're no longer you can actually end up
running a function from a library that's
not actually written in your script so
one way to go around that instead of
running that command just hit ctrl shift
f10
and I will just reset yours our studio
environment which is probably what you
wanted to do anyway but it'll actually
clear everything and then when you run
things from the command line that's
exactly what's going on so I'm gonna
skip this demo for time but are you
really done yet well not really even if
I set the order to a project I end up
with the folder like this right and this
is just that one little simple piece of
analysis and you can already see like
there's a lot of files that got
generated and so I'll write some little
Python code just as a title and you know
how do we fix this so there's this paper
by William Noble and he says hey maybe
we should structure your folders
something like this right like here's
here's an idea and then what we do in
our lab is we do something like this
it's but basically what you really want
is you
data folder a place to store code place
to store output in this case also a
place to store your functions having a
readme files really nice to have and
then you know you can just make
subfolders that's needed the one thing I
noticed is sometimes when you follow
this and you start using it you might
end up with conflicts with images which
is something that I don't know how to
totally minimize yet but we'll skip that
but after you structure all of your
project can you do better well yes of
course you can do better let's look at
the analysis script that we just wrote
it's about 171 lines and what does it do
it loads it cleans that tidies
normalized does some EDA and then fits a
model so then how do we improve on that
so let's just take those six things and
then let's write six different scripts
this way if you all you care about is
the figure you don't have to run your
entire data analysis pipeline you can
just run the little bit of code that
just generates your figure right you
don't have to say like hey run this
could take this script and run run lines
1 to 20 and then skip down to line 300
and then run that line right like you
don't need to do that anymore and it
should be pretty obvious just like what
major Mike and I Rob has talked about
you know it's pretty obvious what or
you're supposed to run this stuff in and
you can give it to someone else and they
probably will have an idea of like hey
where do the plots come from well maybe
a de da script right and so we'll skip
that down so what else
so Rachel Chapman a couple of months
weeks ago gave a talk here in DC our
ladies community so she runs the Seattle
our ladies group and she gave a talk
here in DC about putting together a data
science portfolio and so this is totally
from her slides so what you want to do
is like you'll have a project and you
just want to be able to show that like
you know what you're doing right break
your stuff up into pieces that's all
great but the one thing that you know
she was able to put into words and I
couldn't really convey was you know
avoid like when you go into a meeting no
one really cares about all of the data
processing code that you have so when
you have like a giant arm markdown file
and you're like okay that's great just
go to page 20 because everything else
was just me cleaning data you really
just want to come into a meeting and be
like alright here are my plots and then
just people can talk about that and if
you really need the code which our
markdown gives you it's just the code
for the plus so someone is like what is
this X what is the actual variable being
used well at least you have some
documentation about like what's the
actual variable being used and so that's
where knitter comes in so you can see
like we still have everything in
multiple pieces but only the things that
you know you might want to take into
meeting we'll make those the are
markdown files those uh instead of like
the entire thing but sometimes working
in knitter in our studio projects get
weird because of working directories if
you haven't noticed that if you try to
knit a document it by default thinks
that the working directory is the actual
knitter file and kind of the whole art
studio project thing kind of falls apart
so how do you fix this so Jenny Brian
wrote this package called here it's
based off with this package called our
project route and so when you wrap a
when you wrap a file path around the
here function within here it has a set
of heuristics that tries to find like
what the root directory is right so we
have this art project folder and it
actually knows to look for that art
project folder so now you can actually
say something like you know you don't
really have to change your code the file
path is the same and then you can put it
in your knitter document and you can
click knit and things work and you don't
have to have you know this weird common
thing out of light this only works if
I'm clicking the knit button or like
this only works if I'm running the knit
command in the command line only
downside is when you use the here
package and in a knitter document you
kind of lose the nice ability of tab
completing your way through the
filesystem but maybe maybe someone can
figure that out so I think I might
actually have saved enough time to show
the actual demo so what we have here is
you know this is a little nonsense to go
at least the first one is like I'm
loading a data set just to write it out
but the trick to this is each one of
these scripts the first thing that you
do is really just loading in some data
that the previous script dumped out
right and you know you don't do this
like at the first time you might
right this all out in one giant our
script like I showed you in the first
time but then when you go back and you
start cleaning up your code you'll end
up breaking things up this way just
because at the end of the day you might
just want to rerun the figure and not
the entire pipeline all right so this
stuff is a lot it's really flexible just
you know tweak it as you need so if we
end up down here to the R markdown files
you know it's the same amount of code
it's the same thing now we just put
everything into these are chunks right
and if you all of this code is all on
the github so you can actually click
through it and look at it in more detail
but I what I ended up doing is just
running the entire analysis through the
tidy verse dialect and R and so now you
have this nice situation with using here
and here so you can say like now if I
really click knit before it's gonna
assume that the working directory is
this knitter analysis billboard EDA
folder but now I can say like hey I can
still specify from the root directory
right after I built out my folder
structure you can see I had an analysis
folder a data folder an output folder so
now because it knows that this are super
project exists I can just specify like
hey the file exists on under analysis
billboard EDA 0 for models that are MD
right so that's what all you have to do
to make here the here function work and
so now you end up it in this nice world
where you can actually click knit and
you know this runs like the script if
you were to run this in a command line
but then knit button actually does the
right thing and generates a document
that you wanted right like you know you
don't have to like fudge around with you
know commenting on something just to
render a document
so one thing that this example doesn't
really show is like what do you do with
functions right this is a pretty simple
analysis when things get more
complicated put things into functions so
my my suggestion would be you know
create a capital R folder and if you
ever have a function just dump your
functions in there and then what R has
you know the ability the source file so
one it saves you a lot of typing you can
just source the file under the root
directory R are also has like this
source directory function so you can
just say like source everything in here
for my analysis but what this really is
it's really setting up setting up the
analysis to be turned into a package
right all our needs is a capital R
folder and like two other files and then
this thing can be installed as a package
right so if you end up running this
analysis and another analysis is kind of
related you can now just import all of
your functions right you can turn this
thing into in our package and your
analysis project that we have broken up
is already set up for that so you don't
have to like change what you already
already have so then the next question
was that I like what about like
scholarship or formal documents I'd
prefer to if it gets at at that level
just do everything in tech it just gives
you a lot more control and so there's
two things there's two ways you can
approach that as well you can have a
totally separate repository that's just
your tech just your scholarship and your
writing and then you can have it as a
sibling project so the analysis project
folder is on the same level as your tech
project folder and then if you wanted to
because you have like this output folder
because everything is you know
everything is volved nice in your tech
document you can you know go one
directory up go into your analysis
folder and then under output which is
where all your figures are you can just
insert figures that way all right
another way you can do it is like a
child project so you'll have your report
and then you somehow link in your
analysis folder inside that tech project
right one way if you're using it is you
can use get sub modules for this but
even something as simple as like a
symbolic link or a shortcut this works
as well and so whoops
that works as well and so if you're on
like a UNIX system you can create a
shortcut that says I'm gonna create a
symbolic link here's the folder that I
want the link to and then this dot just
says I'm assuming that I'm in my tech
folder and then your code doesn't really
change you now don't have to say one
directory up you can just say like hey
just go down this file path and insert
my figure there so then you know the
near button puts by default if you're
generating these reports the output or
the HTML rated PDF it's in the source
file location that's pretty annoying
because I wanted stuff in the output
folder why why stuff in the analysis
folder and so the way the solution to do
that is under the our markdown library
there's a function called render and
then there's this parameter called
output directory and then you can just
say hey when I click knit or when I run
the render command like take the output
and put it in this folder but then you
might end up in the situation where like
okay I'm running like the rendered
command from the command line like
there's this all these commands to run
if I have like six scripts like I have
to type all of this stuff out so you
could make a shell script and just and
just runs everything in order
you can use make and then you can take
all those scripts and you can take your
make file and our studio has this
ability to create a build file so you
can actually use our studio to be like
hey rebuild my analysis and so what does
a make file look like so I can do
something like hey I don't want to type
the the analysis billboard eda thing
over and over again so I'll give it a
shortcut by default make will look for a
command called all I'm not going to do
anything with all other than if you type
in make I'll just spit back the possible
commands that you could do but then here
you can see I'm gonna say like give it
essentially like a variable called
billboard eda
and when I say make this these are all
of the commands that need to get run
right and you can see like this make
file becomes self-documenting right legs
like how did you do that well like look
at the make file and everything is like
listed in the order is supposed to be
run and then at the end you know it's
kind of nice to have like a clean thing
so like you know delete the intermediate
intermediate datasets or your figures so
you can just rerun everything in a clean
setting
and so my last demo what does this look
like
so in make you can say make and you can
see like I just said it'll just spit out
my commands I can then say make
billboard eda and I'll just run through
all of those six scripts and then in
here you can see that all of my plots
and figures would have been dumped out
into it output folder that way alright
so in some use are like I said doesn't
matter where you are in your are
learning career you can always you know
hopefully you've learned something and
then slowly as you you can always add a
little bit more structure to your
projects and then hopefully you'll end
up in data science data cleaning nirvana
so since these sides are posted I've
just linked to a bunch of resources if
you care about like hey that slide deck
looks cool how did Dan make it uses
something called mark Jes like I said a
lot of people who think about this all
converge into the same roughly the same
ideas
so Jenny Brian John miles why John bliss
Trek they've all you know cackle this
problem in many different ways and have
also all written about it and so for
that I would say thanks this is my dog
I've had him for two years he just
turned four and that's it
you